this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
happy valentine's day the joint is
brought to you by
honey listen to me when it comes to
supplements on it is number one they've
got this black label
alpha brain it is listen i started my
cycle last week and i'm feeling
tremendous
they have the little drink on it's the
dehydration
the uh alpha brain listen you know me
alpha brain is the key also new mood
tremendous
uh what's the other one i like a lot
shroom tech sport and immune will do
wonders for you but who the hell am i go
to honor.com right now
look through the supplements i'm going
to get you 10 off your first order i
can't do this with the club bells or the
kettlebells but as far as supplements i
got you so go to honor.com right now
read up on the alpha brain 100 percent
money back guarantee even if you don't
like it that's belief in your product
go down it if you buy something press
code
joey in church and get 10 off your order
delivered right to your house that's
what island is all about the joint is
also brought to you by zip recruiter
listen it's february things are going to
start to lighten up right now do you
know that 90 of employees
plan to make employee experience a top
priority in 2022
after all a happy workplace is key to
keeping great employees i know that jobs
are offering flexible work schedules and
working from home are going to be big in
2022 and if you need to add more
employees to your team there's zip
recruiter and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free
at ziprecruit.com joey their matching
technology helps you find the right
people for the right roles fast four out
of five employees who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day no wonder zip recruiter is
the number one rated hiring site in the
us and if you're looking for a job they
can help you too ziprecruiter is amazing
whether you have a small business or a
large business over 100 employees zip
recruiter can help you find the perfect
employees for your workplace
try it for free at this exclusive web
address ziprecruiter.com
joey again that ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire let's get this party started mikey
we got a podcast to do it's the joint
[__]
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 14th saint valentine's
day happy valentine's day to everybody
hopefully you got a date and you'll get
your balls licked and you're manscaped i
manscaped the nut sack i manscaped
everything not that i'm gonna have sex
but you know you always got to be
prepared
in cases of recovering [__] suck in the
neighborhood if you don't have a
valentine's day no big [__] deal go
to a bar you know do what you work your
[__] magic there's a bunch of women
that don't have valentine's day so you
don't have to be [__] lonely you know
what i'm saying that's all i'm just
trying to help you out you can't listen
to podcasts all day and whack off you
got to [__] make her appear you know
what i'm saying you're sitting there all
day fantasizing trying to bang one out
[__] that that went out the window
you're going to dress up a little bit
and you're just going to walk to a bar
and maybe talk to somebody i'm not
guaranteeing uh you know you're gonna
get laid when i was a kid there was a
book
like how to get laid there was all these
books like how to meet women
all this [__] gary listen those books
never helped anybody
trust me i'm telling you you could buy
those books for i thought they think it
was like
9.99
how to pick up women or something in the
80. i forget what the book they had like
three book series if you want to google
them maybe they're still online you know
teach how to pick up women with
sideburns and [__]
[__] showing up how are you yeah
because the book is from the 70s you're
going to show up with [__] sideburns
right
no no the woman ain't got sideburns when
i was a kid women had more hair on their
face i haven't seen a woman with hair
since i moved back to jersey when i was
a kid there was a couple barbarella
looking [__] that had little
chins on the hair on their chins and
[__] when i was a kid i just thought it
was normal for a girl to have [__]
hair on her face then i moved out to the
west coast you don't see no wolfie type
chicks you know what i'm saying and by
the way i want to give a shout out to
rachel wolfson
just jackass and [__] to death
badass [__] wolfy you know
works hard
and there you have it guys for you
[__] that think it can't happen
you know man wolfie works hard she
smokes a lot of dope
she's beautiful
she got an audition for jackass i was
supposed to work with her that weekend
not on jackass but i had totally if you
want to because she features [__] uh
felipe
she does her own gig she works with a
boyfriend
but she's really cool wolfie she came on
the church and we jacked a little bit
and i could tell she was gonna do
something like oh it's just a matter of
time
they give her a weed show or something
she's good looking you know she's funny
i mean she's not like a comedy store
comic yet
but she's [__] getting there she
works hard and
she did the movie bro she was on kimmel
she was on a couple things they're
blowing her up i text her
and i said congratulations and guys
this is what it's all about
is seeing somebody you were in the
[__] trenches with
make it i swear to god
it's such a good [__] feeling people
i love it when one of those girls
the chick from [__] the comedy store
was a bartender and ended up on [__]
cyanide live
and you know she was getting spots at
the store
here and there and she just kept getting
funnier and funnier and funnier and she
started working on yeah she was
bartending but they give you spots at
the store so there's a fallout there
there she goes
punky was in the [__] room killing
him so
it's a great feeling even if i'm out of
it i'm watching the success that uh
rachel's getting and it's [__] great
i hope they give her a show or
something you know she's uh she comes
from a [__] smart ass family
they're all involved with the law i mean
that's why i always dug her because when
i would talk to be about the law or
something like that her mother's a judge
how cool is that your mother's a judge
your sister's the d.a it's like being in
an episode of blue bloods and [__] for
breakfast you're there who are you going
to convict today some [__] puerto
ricans stabbed an old lady in the
supermarket
that's breakfast right there that's an
exciting [__] breakfast what do you
got today my i'm going to [__]
sentence oj to 20 years
that [__] [__] sucker and kidnapping
because she did she had something to do
with the oj trial the mother i don't
know if you guys know that but
it's always great to see somebody
get in there it's a it's a great feeling
you know i'm an old man where the [__]
am i going but i look at these young
guys that were there at the store
or the laugh factory with me or the
improv and they're very respectful all
the time
and every time i saw them they were out
they weren't trying to make contact i'm
making contacts with contacts with these
[__] fake producers at the bugger you
make better contacts at the [__]
laundry mat you know what i'm saying
contacts the days the contacts are over
you're making contacts on the internet
you go out and [__] work at night and
that's the bottom [__] line
when mike came all today we're talking
about pets
and you know it's it's [__] weird how
pets do affect your life
i signed on the woop app
and uh it's the the watch that rogan and
those guys wore when they would do the
sober octobers
and you know it tells you how much
you're pushing it tells you recovery
that's why i was always walking around
saw
so i wanted to know what the [__] was
going on
i forgot what i was gonna tell you
[__]
what's that talking about
the the what
the whoop about yeah the whoop app and
[__] like that
and uh
it tells you how much you slept it tells
you
i [__] dig it i i i don't do it for
the high level stuff
but it tells you uh your recovery your
[__] oxygen
how much you slept that night it's so
weird ever since i've been i've had this
watch like now i go to sleep every night
trying to beat last night's school
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
like a little [__] contest for
yourself i didn't get it to be hercules
i didn't get it to jump off buildings or
anything like that you know i think it
was a good idea in fact i didn't even
know rogan and bert and those guys had
it when i went to jiu jitsu sean the
coach said to me you should get a whoop
watch if you don't know how much you
recuperate and whatever the [__] is
going on with you
so when i got to watch i was talking to
red band about it how long it took me to
get it he's like just call rogan he's
got a bunch of them at the house
they're probably the three point knows
they're not the four points not that you
[__] give a [__]
but it's so weird like i always
didn't sleep for years i didn't [__]
sleep guys for years i was cracking a
joke the other day and it's true when i
was 10 i looked like i was 22.
you know when i was 10 years old i
literally got 22. and when i was at 20 i
looked like i was [__] 40 already
there was no coming back for uncle joey
and i think it wasn't the drugs i don't
think it was any of that [__]
i think it was the lack of [__] sleep
like just a really
this whole period has really
dawned on me how bad my sleeping was all
those years just [__] horrific listen
six hours
is okay
but it ain't gonna [__] cut it
and like now like i i'm getting like the
last four nights i've slept [__]
eight hours i feel great yesterday i
woke up feeling like [__] dick
uh i didn't do [__] all day i was just
broke in the [__] i mean i did [__] you
know when you have a kid you just can't
sit on a [__] couch all day but as
far as i mean work it out and do [__] i
couldn't do anything i walked around we
did this we did that was a great [__]
weekend watched the [__] ufc's
they were [__] fantastic uh
i think i fell asleep before the israel
fight to be honest with you guys i fell
asleep when derek lewis got knocked out
yes i did bet
tuivasa i can't [__] believe i won
because i had better
the guy who fought jan and khmer derrick
brunson that was a bust out because i
thought he was going to win and retire
that was a bust out
[Music]
then i lost with somebody else earlier
so i'm like tonight's not my night
and i go [__] it let me just see what
tia tuavos is [__] doing here tonight
he's 27 years old you guys know i'm a
derrick lewis fan but i'm a fan of money
i i like to win my little 25 bucks you
know i'm saying and since tuivasa was a
[__] underdog here's the problem that
you got when you bet those like i saw
like john annex picks
and all these people had their twitter
pics and [__] you always they all picked
up you know
artisanal they all picked
derek lewis and they all picked
somebody else that was in one of the
earlier fights i forget who the [__] it
was
it was like everybody picked them so i
knew it was gonna be a perfect night
that's why i don't like betting fights
the day before anything you bet as
you're watching
because i knew somebody was going to go
down last night i just didn't know who
if derek lewis and [__] the other guy
would have won
then i would have bet against
israel i didn't even bet that [__]
fight i could care less i just wanted
the upset
and after that i don't know i put my
head on the couch next to you know i
woke up it was two o'clock and joe rogan
was there yelling about something
unfucking my tv i have no idea what the
[__] it was
and that was it i went upstairs to hit
the crib and i woke up [__] the
lord's day at 8 30 ready for the [__]
super bowl but that's all over that's it
football's done till next [__] year
and now we gotta [__] rest our
laurels on the nba
college basketball and baseball in two
[__] months not that you guys give a
[__] nobody really does i mean the super
bowl more people bet the [__] super
bowl than any other sporting event in
the world even people who've never
[__] gambled before look what
happened in new york new york opened
that [__] gambling june 5th
january 4th january they got 1.2 billion
[__] dollars in gambling and that's
what they tell them you know what i'm
saying that's a lot of [__] money
that's how much people are [__]
gambling i understand we don't have a
middle class left but who the [__] is
gambling this much and they're saying
that they got like 80 something percent
or people who've never gambled before
which is just astro [__] nominal but
it's a it's a different day to [__]
gamble now you can just go on your phone
you got [__] draftkings you got
fanduel you got bet mgm you got 22
[__] services and they're all giving
you [__] getus to [__] uh sign up
but to me i've always been happy with
draftkings i tried like three other
services and draftkings just felt more
real like i was i wasn't betting with
some [__] the jamaican bank i'm not
gonna get my money tomorrow i don't like
making those [__] silly bets i don't
like putting my credit card out there
that's there's a lot of wacky dudes that
love that [__] you know what i take it
easy on the internet you know amazon you
could trust
nobody breaches [__] amazon right
amazon never amazon never sends you an
email with being [__]
the russians cracked into my account
because it don't happen amazon they're
tough they got people there you [__]
around with amazon that's a big account
that's a lot of people i want to know
how many people are members of [__]
amazon
like i know my wife is amazon prime and
she [__] loves it i heard
that the only way you're going to be
able to watch the nfl next year is
through
amazon
it's real [__] interesting i want to
show you guys something
in my world these are the best edibles
and you guys know i've eaten everything
i like eating edibles that are clean i
don't want to hang over you ever eat a
[__] pot cookie
and you're [__] hung over the next
day and you're like what's the hangover
same hangover you got when you drink
pina coladas you dumb [__] sugar
all this sugar and this [__] i swear
to god when you i made a batch of
brownies this week
not good guys
not good i don't know
it was a
failure to launch as they say it was
just a failure to launch i put an eighth
of [__] cocoa weed in that
[__] cut it up with his scissors
didn't grind it
cut it up so it retains everything in
that [__] and on top of that
i put maybe like two crams of high level
keef in that [__]
and i gotta tell you something i made
the brown the brownies i used the uh
the san francisco chocolate company i
didn't use the [__] generic one oh my
god and i threw some walnuts in that
[__] yowzer yowza yowza if the thc
don't get you the [__] wall analogy
will but i gotta tell you man i had like
two or three of them
you know what i didn't have any mike
wasn't around i made him on tuesday i
didn't have any guinea pigs just myself
and i think i slept i fell asleep i got
up and the whoop told me i [__] took
a nap i didn't even [__] know
but
yeah the whoop will tell you you took a
nap and [__] but these to me these are
25 milligrams these still got [__]
kicking them plus the 25 milligrams have
a sleepy time flavor in these [__]
and they don't sponsor the show nothing
i'm just trying to help you
[__] out for your edible
experience you know what i'm saying 25s
will put you to sleep my recommendation
always [__] go for 100 but also work
yourself up to it i know professionals
professionals
that have had bad experiences with this
what do you mean bad experiences joey
did they crash the bus no they just
slept longer than they should have
they fell asleep with their clothes on
you know i'm saying when they had a
flight
[__] like that people didn't know where
they were look what abx sent me this
last week look at this meteor
of edibles and [__] like that if you
could determine how many 200 milligrams
are in this mother oh [__]
three of them that's it three of them
won't [__] it there you go mikey that's
your present for the week
i i would take one now but i got [__] to
do today i can't i usually take three of
those two hundreds at about eight
o'clock
at about 9 30 you do start feeling dark
you start thinking to yourself oh my god
i got i got diabetes you just feel weird
for like
you really do feel weird that's one
thing i will when these things hate you
they hit you a little harder than other
things they do they like the [__]
they're like the [__] tuivasa of
edibles they hit hard
they [__] hit hard for the first
three or four minutes you're like am i
losing my breath am i gonna pass out but
then once you pass [__] what's those
people looking for valhalla once you
arrive and [__] valhalla oh my god
and that's the first song you hear
[__] done in it
the [__] led zeppelin uh
whatever the [__] cashmere
dog these edibles are tremendous and
like i said they're not a sponsor of the
podcast nothing i'm just trying to keep
you [__] tip top magoo in the
[__] loop of life
so i'm recommending these i know a lot
of you people like to hate your [__]
edibles hey i ain't mad at you but i
swear to god
in the last 10 years
and you guys have been with me a lot of
years you guys know i've had my edibles
and
i've never have edibles hit me as hard
as abx's and
those 15 milligram
gummy bears i bought from slump kitchen
those things were [__] strong guys
and when i tell you they were strong i
ate 300 milligrams and i didn't know
what the [__] i was
that's [__] strong okay
and i ended up buying seven boxes of
those things because they had a sale
holy [__]
i slept on those [__] i mean
that's what i'm going back to the
mattresses here like i said the watch
helps me sleep and now like every night
i'm trying to [__] i gotta break
eight hours now i gotta [__] today i
gotta read up how to increase your rents
how to go deeper
deep deep deep i thought by eating
penalties that's as deep as you could go
but sorry charlie i can't they're great
edibles but they're not gonna take you
into that deep
deep rem sleep that you're looking for
so i gotta figure out i gotta read the
book sleep again i gotta do a bunch of
[__] things and figure this [__] out
but i'm feeling a lot better i'm looking
a lot better i got some [__] going on
this week
you guys will find out about pretty
[__] soon you know
mike and i were talking about [__]
pets before like
i don't know if you guys have cats i
don't know if you guys have dogs but i
gotta be honest with you
you gotta have something
you really gotta have something in your
life to break it up i went without
animals
you know but i couldn't have an animal i
was if i was an animal how can you have
an animal when you are a [__] animal
you know
and i tell you i could feel the calmness
effect
i didn't have
i grew up with like dogs i had dogs for
a while and i got to be honest i cannot
tell you what happened to these dogs i
cannot honestly tell you when i was like
10 or 11
i got these two dogs
um
and i don't know what my mom was at war
with them i was going to catholic school
and one guy kept breaking out
so my mom got rid of him and then
like
10 months before my mother died i got a
dog named crystal
because her crystal thc he was white
with a couple of brown spots he looked
just like when you opened up aluminum
foil and you saw crystal tac it was like
that dark
white
you know jerry what are you talking
about if it's white how can it be dark
you know what i'm [__] talking about
some white is [__] light eyeballs on
fire this was like a darker white and
you could see a couple of brown spots
and when i got the dog
i called the dog crystal thc
short for crystal just in case the cops
were around you couldn't say crystal tea
so i just called the crystal
i took crystalline when she was about
six weeks old and i [__] loved that
dog that dog my stepfather was out of
the house i had trained them myself to
[__] in the yard i'd pick up the [__] i
was really responsible with it like i
was
i was trying to be the man of the house
at that time so that was part of my
thing like i didn't want my mother
telling me you got to clean the piss up
or it's time for you to walk the dog i
love that [__] dog
but when my mother died i couldn't take
crystal with me
to the bender's house so
i gave it to this lady nina and i would
go over there from time to time and jump
in the [__] dog house
with the dog and cry and then i lost
contact with them and that was history
but i was always i like dogs cats
i wasn't really a cat guy growing up
until my mother died and the benders had
a cat
and at first i didn't know when you're
[__] petting them their parent you're
like what the [__] you don't want to
touch them and then i started liking and
then she started bringing pigeons home
and birds home her name was frisky john
bender had a cat named frisky with like
a missing half ear beautiful
tough as [__]
you know that like you know you'd wake
up in the morning there'd be a [__]
there'd be a [__] uh squirrel in your
living room half dead like looking at
you and frisky would be [__] stabbing
that [__] it was it was surreal
so i kind of like this cat for the
hunter she was but i still didn't know
anything about cats and i remember going
to aspen colorado
and going to my buddy steve chavalny's
house he was dating his white chick and
she had cats she was like a white hippie
chick with crystals the whole [__]
deal and she had cats and i'll never
forget that the cat jumped on my [__]
lap and i was petting it and listen
again i didn't know about cats so when
the cat was their parent i was scared
shitless i thought the [__] cat was
gonna attack me so i'll never forget i
pushed the cat off me we were watching
like eddie murphy delirious
it was a double date my me and my
girlfriend at the time went over there i
did not know how to act around the cat
i pushed that [__] cat off me and i
go [__] you [__] and after that i
didn't have a cat like i was like nah
cats just aren't me and then
when i met my little [__] indian
terry
she had that one cat and then
she saved another cat and then she saved
another cat and i got acquainted with
the cat
but then i started feeling different
like once i got the cats
i started feeling differently after
about a year or so like i started
feeling
i don't know like i belonged to
something the cat would make me come
home you know i didn't have much money
when i had those cats in the beginning
you know mike mike you know it was funny
that night some people were talking like
when you did comedy go listen when i did
calm there was down to bare minimum it
was either underwear or cocaine you know
what i'm saying you want to do coke here
then you can't wear underwear that's why
i didn't wear underwear i was down to
like three socks you know what i'm
saying and no underwear no white
t-shirts why because you got to give
something up you know what i'm saying so
when even when it came to the cats i
went in my pocket if i had 22
i would take
10 and go buy cat food
it put me in a position where i couldn't
get [__] coke
because you could always get a 20
package of coke but you can't get a
[__] 10 you know but i would do that
i would put myself in those positions
for the cats it was the weirdest thing
that i started reading about cats there
was a guy at the comedy store great
comic irish comic he was good friends
with jimmy schubert his name was dan
barton he wrote for kennison early on
[__] great writer smart guy
and one night we just got in a
conversation about cats like early on
when i first got the three cats
and i didn't know much about him i was
just talking to him and he was like
[__] making my head blow up
telling me about the cats in egypt if
you killed a cat
if you had a if a cat died if you owned
a cat in egypt
you had to bring the cat like the
neighborhood doctor if there was any
uh foul play involved if the cat didn't
look like he died in natural causes
they'd [__] kill you
that's how in the cleopatra era all
those [__]
they love cats that's why you see all
those figurines of skinny cats and [__]
i forget what those skinny cats are
called who the [__] knows siamese the
other ones it's i got that the other
night i was watching
the motley crew movie and the guy sits
next to nikki six
and he goes try this persian heroine and
the guy goes nikki six like what are you
talking about persia there's no [__]
persian guy goes yeah yeah like that cat
in the disney movie this is when you're
doing heroin is what you're talking
about
and nikki six goes to what the [__] are
you talking about you stupid
[__] that's a siamese cat
a siamese cat they gotta be crossed with
the woman at the cross side anyway
what the [__] are we talking about
persia siamese whatever i don't give a
[__]
the situation was i just something they
gave me a weird warm cats and then my
wife we had the situation in the
backyard with samurai [__] 82 000
cats and having 16 [__] kitten
litters so we started adopting cats for
people and we got stuck with them listen
i'm not saying we got stuck with them
after a while you fall in love with them
and you're like i'm not giving them away
now they're comfortable here why confuse
them why [__] you know
so cats have just
been in my life now for 22 [__] years
and i'm down to two of them
the last one from the samurai tribe
and the one that came into my house in
north hollywood gray that we took off
the [__] from the neighbor we clipped
it from the neighbor the neighbor knew
the neighbor handed me the [__] cat
but
real quick a little break from the
action the joint is sponsored by better
help online online therapy listen it's
valentine's day relationships take work
and a lot of us will drop anything to do
to get help to someone we care about
we'll go out of our way to treat other
people well but how often do we give
ourselves the same treatment we don't i
invest in myself every monday morning
with my therapy this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you to
take care of the most important
relationship the one that you have with
yourself like i told you for years you
got to be a good friend to yourself you
got to make sure you go to sleep you got
to make sure you eat right and drink
water and
there's nothing wrong with talking to
somebody i love that i have dana in my
life she helps me out i was telling my
man theo that i wish i had a therapist
full-time when i was doing comedy it
would have really helped me out a lot
whether it's hitting the gym or making
time for a haircut
or even trying therapy you are your
greatest asset so invest time and effort
into yourself like you do for other
people better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and chat
sessions with your therapist it's so
much more affordable on personal therapy
and you can be matched with the
therapist
in under 48 hours give it a try and see
why over 2 million people have worked to
better help
the joint is sponsored by better help
and listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz give it a shot
it helped me a lot thank you and now
back to the podcast
i was telling mike once this [__] cat
goes down that's the end
that's the end of that cat line like
that's it the mother's done
samurai disappeared way before we left
hollywood
it's the end
and it's been like a 17 year we've had
17 years of those [__] cats
from that same [__] lit and this is
the last one so it's like
listen i'm not sad because i've accepted
that she's got to go
i still think i'm super bad like i still
dream about superbad at night from time
to time he was the cat that took me off
cocaine in 2007. we're going on 15
[__] years he's been dead
three years and i still never [__]
slipped some
a little kiss for [__] samurais [__]
samurai super bad up there in cat heaven
right now eating salmon and [__] getting
his dick sucked by siamese cat with no
eye that got hit by a car
who the [__] knows
the other day i was looking at at notes
from the book you know we're going to
hand this book in the next week or two
it's
we're not going to talk tomorrow because
eric is uh we're not talking until
wednesday eric is out of town till
wednesday but
that's what i did this weekend seriously
at nine i just turned the tv off and i
outlined the last two chapters and then
i started making an outline
for the overview of the book you know
and uh
i was just looking through it it's it's
a lot of material
but one of the most interesting
chapters in that [__] book
and i even read like four or five pages
of it
was i did a thing for it was the
weirdest
you know harry called me one day
he was doing the
storytelling show you know
and ari and me used to talk a lot on the
road
like we used to talk about comedy
jokes food chinese food being a jew you
know we used to talk about a lot of [__]
all those years with rogan down the road
i mean i know aria over 20 years
my wife knows zarya even longer so
and uh i don't know he came to me when
then he goes you gotta hit me with a
different story doug you gotta hit me
with something fresh unique
and i couldn't come up with anything you
know prison stories whatever
and just something made me think about
my mother and uh
and uh
zarita you know i would i did a podcast
about friendship when i was doing beauty
and the beast
and a lot of people reached out to me
from that podcast i mean if you
think people reached out to me after i
told the hooker story
a lot of people reached out to me after
the friendship thing and they were like
dog you hit it
on the head i never thought of those
things you know
one of the toughest things in life is
being a friend to somebody that's it's
it's a tough job because you don't know
whether you're pushing you don't know
whether you're pulling
you always
uh
you just want to be a good friend you
know
i've lived in jersey i lived in colorado
i've lived in seattle
and you guys know i have great friends i
just i love my friends i let them know
that i love them
because this is what's worked for me
over the years
and i let them know that if i could help
them i could help them but the most
important thing is that we're friends
with dogs we're down
the whole [__] thing yeah you have
acquaintances in your life we all have a
thousand acquaintances that we
we like we
say hello to you know what's going on
but we really don't know anything much
more on that maybe they're putting up a
wall maybe we're putting up a wall
whatever you have to you have to tell
the difference between your
acquaintances and the [__] who
live and die for you i'll tell you what
you can live to be 70 and have one
[__] that'll live and die for
you
and that's more than a lot of people
because dog your wife will [__] leave
you
you know and i watch it's the truth i
want you to know these things in life
before you get involved in this [__]
your wife will leave you your mother
will die your father will die and you
will find yourself [__] alone one day
okay at one at any point in life
i don't give a [__] who you are when
your parents are off this planet or
maybe
one plan one dad or maybe your mom is
gone but your dad is still alive you're
a lonely [__] on this planet you
really never noticed until you go home
and think about it you don't want to
think about it because you know it'll
[__] depress the [__] out of you you
know
and then you have to look at the people
around you you know you think about dane
cook his brother rob from him and i'm
not putting negative [__] in your mind i
just want you to know the possibilities
that are out there you think of you know
wives ex-wives you know you think of
family members you know it's it's you
can never judge who it is
but all you could do is be a great
[__] friend you know
when i was a kid in new york city i had
friends on the block and [__]
since my mom had a little bit of money i
always played it down
and i would help the kids out you know
buy them a soda or something i'd always
say i found the dollar let's go get four
iced teas i was always very generous
that way
i always wanted to help somebody on the
street i don't mind
if if you know when you're a kid how
many [__] kids their parents have
dope both parents are working maybe they
give you a dollar to go out with if i
stole ten dollars when i was a kid half
of it was [__] yours you know or
whatever if i made 10 bucks on something
if we pushed the sled
or we helped push a car and the guy gave
us 10 gave me 10 you know i always gave
everybody a little more than what i got
because my mom
had money in the house but it wasn't
until my mom died
that i found out what
well i'm lying to you guys
while she was alive
i witnessed it
and i didn't know
i got to be honest with you guys
and god please help me for a couple
[__] years
i thought my mother was gay
that's the [__] up thing i've ever
said in my life
there was a couple years there where
it would hit me like i was
maybe 12 13 14
it would just come into my mind and i go
you know what
i didn't want to think about if my
mother's gay and i got nothing against
being gay and nothing it's just when
it's your mother or your father you know
can you imagine living your life and
thinking your father's gay
like you find like a leather whip in
your [__]
and your father's thing and now how ho
hum
down would you be if you found out your
dad was gay i don't know for what reason
maybe you're happy
i'm saying if he was with your mom like
vito from the sopranos
like if you had a friend like vito
and you found out
if your father was rita i'm sorry and
you found out your father was gay
i mean you wouldn't
but you don't know how to take it at a
young age so
from 12 to 14 i really thought
yeah no no no it's it's it's the sun
went crazy after he died but
it's just so weird for a couple years
there
you know my mom would talk to the zurita
lady
if they didn't talk on the phone ten
times a day they didn't [__] talk
when i woke up in the morning they were
on the phone to go to school
when i got home from school they were on
the [__] phone
before she went to new york at night
you know before she went to a bar at
night i'm sorry she was on the phone
with the writer on the way to a mec game
she'd have to pull over and calls the
writer from payphone
it's not like zaraiter slept at the
house or my mom slept over there my mom
would go over there
there's seven days in a week my mother
was over there five days a week
on any mission she made to new york
there was always a stoppage to write his
house
for 15 minutes to try on a blouse do a
bump of coke talk about the mets and
what tom seaver was wearing the night
before and just to check in with each
other for years she took me up those
[__] stairs
for years let me tell you something i
love going as a writer's house let's get
this out of the way when i was a kid i
lived on the lower east of the upper
west side
yeah we tortured mr martini
we had a couple kids on the block that
were crazy but for the most part it was
a very conservative [__] neighborhood
what do i mean by that was very white
there was you know it wasn't harlem
there was a couple puerto ricans but it
wasn't harlem at that time when you went
to [__] harlem it was [__] black
beautiful puerto rican and jewish a lot
of [__] jews in harlem in those days
what's that talking about mike i'm
[__] stoned i can't get high before
these podcasts we got too high before
the podcast today which is good you need
to [__] loosen up a little bit when i
[__] started to join i thought this
is going to be like a a stock podcast or
a businessman podcast i can't smoke
because i can't smoke in my house
but i had sweaters on because i was
looking at a video the other day what
was i thinking i would put these nice
sweaters on [__] that [__] this is no
[__]
this ain't no business man [__]
podcast so now we do some edibles we
smoke some dope
yeah so i thought they were [__] gay
so but finally when i was 14 i figured
out they weren't
finally when i was 14 i figured out
something i'm like wait a second what am
i an [__] you know like when a
thought comes into your mind and you
don't want to process it
that's what i was doing when i was like
14 or 15
one day i just processed it because
when i was about 14 or 15 that's as a
writer started coming over to jersey
mall my mom didn't have the bar
in new york and her operation is now on
a bar around the corner
so zoraida would come over
like about
two years before my mother died so ryder
would come over two nights a week we
would eat they would [__] smoke dope
they would giggle
and then zerata would go back to [__]
long island at night you know so i was
like you know what i think they're not
gay they're not in the bedroom eating
each other's monkeys that [__]
downstairs talking and switching blouses
and talking about dresses and [__]
but
like more and more
i think the first my first part of my
life
my mom was helping out zarina and then
the later part of my life so ryder
turned around and was helping my mom
more
i think my mom wouldn't let me know what
was going on but [__] zarida would
she would confide in sorry what was
going on you know my stepfather had left
my mother lost the bar
there was just a bunch of [__] going on
my mom let me know a lot of the [__]
that was going on but then again
on the other hand she wouldn't let me
know what was going on which was cool
with me at the time
i just wish i knew about it like today i
wish i knew about more of what she was
struggling with and i and when she died
i realized she was struggling from a
broken heart
what ralphie may died of and
sometimes a lot of people die of it it's
just a cardiac arrest or a heart attack
or whatever the [__] they do but
it's really a broken [__] heart but
those last two years
was a writer was just dynamite to my mom
and then after my mom died
she took care of me
for close to [__] four years you know
i was on the phone with her every day i
tried to fill in like i
i didn't know what a fr
i didn't know what friendship entailed
as a whole i didn't really know that
and now they call it right or die or
whatever when i was growing up it was
you know
we breathe for one another that's it
those are the
those are the words like listen i
breathe for you so anything you need any
situation you get into call we'll
[__] knock them on ourselves or will
land a helicopter and throw a grenade
you know you talk [__]
but uh the meaning is always there you
know we breathe for one another and like
i said it's very hard to determine you
know you have acquaintances
that maybe you want to be better friends
with well then you have to breathe them
a little bit
you have to show them that you breathe
they're not just going to decide and
make you they're [__] homey you know
but why do you want to be that person's
friend is it because
they can get you a job they can do
something for you or do you genuinely
does that person make you feel good when
you're with them you laugh you giggle
money is no [__] option
if i don't have the 20 for lunch he's
got the 20 for lunch if he doesn't got
the 20 for lunch i got the 20 for lunch
it's that type of [__] relationship
you know
zarida was just there for my mom and it
was
[__] beautiful to see
but
after
my mom died that's when this woman's
friendship
because listen anybody could be your
friend when you're alive
anybody could be your friend when you
got a pocket full of money and a pocket
full of blow and a big dick right
anybody could be your friend in fact if
you got a pocket full of money in a
pocket full of blow even if your dick is
an inch it's [__] two feet you're the
[__] savage man because you got what
it takes to get you there they're gonna
be so [__] up they're gonna be
confused on the dick what i'm trying to
[__] say is that after
my mom died
like i was in [__] you know when your
mom dies or your father dies or your
brother dies
the first day of the week
you're not even believing this is
happening
like you really don't believe this is
you
you question it for a minute not even
like a second and you go you know what i
gotta go put my shirt and shoes on my
suit i gotta go take a shower you try to
avoid thinking about it but once you get
to the wake
and you look at the picture of that
person in the casket
it becomes a [__] reality like
everything else is background music once
that that person's in the casket and
that casket's open you got whatever
three hours you know it used to be two
days of awake
now because of covert and restrictions
it's one [__] screening
everybody go the [__] home you know
things have changed which i like that
better why draw it the [__] out do a
three-hour everybody pay their respects
if you can make it you can make it if
you can't move on we understand seven
flowers light a candle say a prayer
whatever the [__] you want to say but
at that [__] funeral i remember
feeling at that the first afternoon of
my mother's weight
i just remember feeling there like my
[__] heart was in my hand
and all of a sudden i'm sitting in the
[__]
the viewing room if you call it i'm
maybe 30 feet away from the casket i'm
looking at it as a whole like the big
pic like if i was gonna shoot the
funeral i'd be shooting it from back
there like the whole picture and then
i'd do isolated shots people's faces you
know whatever the [__]
but i was just sitting there man minding
your own business no just think about it
it's the afternoon
it's five maybe
i'm not high
i just got to the funeral parlor
i haven't really walked up to see my
mother i don't need to not right now
i'm going to have plenty of time to make
my peace with i just want to sit and get
the tone of the room
and see what's going on you know and
i'm heartbroken i don't even know where
to start and the next thing you know i
hear [__] you
what the [__] did i tell you and i'm
like
and my hearing [__] voices this is
what happens when you lose a loved one
and i'm hearing better singal
yes
what the [__] and i bust out and i go
into the hallway and there's a writer
and she's got rivero
the funeral director who had just been
poor rivero he had just been abused
for the last
hour
from the minute we walked into that
funeral parlor
rivera was getting tortured not by me
not by the writer
my mom had a crew of friends
that were [__] boozers from the bar
like you know those that crew friends
that drink with you every day
my mom had like eight of them from that
bar and guru they were just [__]
these people these cubans were crazy
and they drank beer all day well listen
let's say the wake started at four
at ten after [__] four
these [__] walked in
go find the biggest beer cooler you
could find in america like those long
long long igloos you know which ones i'm
talking about they're like four feet
long egg glues
they these cubans walk them with one of
those [__] things
the other guy i'm not doing alberto had
a case of [__] pinch
whiskey that they just walked in with
and some other guy had like a keg or
something else and i'll never forget
just sitting there and rivera was a nice
cuban man very tan
dark-skinned handsome he walks up but he
wasn't a heavy he was a funeral director
he walked out he said guys guys guys
look at that
what's going on here you guys know i'll
lose my liquor license all this [__] and
one of the guys just went in his pocket
took out like two one dollar bill and
put it in [__]
uh referrals and jacket pockets pocket
and they're like rivero this was
happening today this is it
and they walked into like a make-believe
kitchen that was back there in between
the visitation rooms and they started
putting that beer on isis [__] with the
keg and rivero kept opening the door
it's not about the money i'm gonna lose
my that rivero then close the [__]
door don't let the licensed guy in i'm
like oh no they're just torturing this
rivero guy he finally just left threw
his hands up they started setting up a
[__] bar
they started putting bottles out like in
one of the [__] corn like they took
all the flowers off it it was not good
guys like a [__] bartender you ever
go to like a wedding they have like a
bartender at the wedding by himself no
busboy and he just makes [__] you
know whiskey tonics or whatever whiskey
sauers margaritas they had like [__]
some dude making his name was miguel
he's still alive in miami
he had the first shift of bartending at
the [__] thing they had the shaker
i'll never forget that they had a
[__] shaker like i'll never feel like
oh my god
i got to go into the [__] visitation
room
so that was the first situation like 10
after
then at like 4 30 there was something
else that happened some people want to
the santeria people came in
and they wanted to cut a chicken before
the event started
in the back room and then cut a chicken
and dragged the blood on no no no
and now i'm embarrassed because listen
my friends are all [__] white people
they're legit white italian nice people
couple jews couple germans you know
don't [__]
embarrass me in front of these guys
there was certain women girls that i
knew that i told them not to come to my
mother's wake there were certain people
i said do me a favor if you came to the
wake i know i know where your heart is
but don't come
but [__] uh
just don't come because i don't want you
to see that whole santeria thing when
they [__] came in with a chicken and
a bag and they were going to kill the
chicken and there was like four dark
dark skin cubans
with [__] hats on and santeria
medallions and they wanted to kill a
chicken rivero was [__] losing at
this poor bastard and then not even
20 minutes later
zarida is choking him because he put the
wrong dress on my mother that was
tremendous
i told you to put the [__] blue dress
you son of a [__] and poor rivero
by that time would have jumped out of
his [__] skin he did not want to do
this [__] wake but
um i remember that i went up to the
right and i tried to calm it down
but then it all dawned on me
my mother and zarina were cut from the
same cloth
and i remember as a writer letting them
loose i'm going to have a drink with the
cubans and me just like just sitting
there kind of embarrassed but not really
and that's when it dawned on me like i
was sad until the time
zarita
choked rivero
after that gradually my sadness went
away because i started finding out
their friendship
that would like i sat down and going
wait a second
this crazy cuban [__]
just went at the funeral director
for a mistake with a dress but no no no
it doesn't matter what dress she pass on
she's dead it's not like she's going to
the titanic for a party it's like she's
going to the [__] studio 54
she's dead
what difference
is the dress
and
that's when it dawned on me it didn't
matter what difference the dress was
i went up to her you know five hours
late and i asked her what the [__] was
it with the dress and she was like that
was her favorite dress she had just
bought it she had once mentioned to me
that if she could get married again
i listen i don't give a [__] but just
the fact
that somebody stuck up for you
after you were dead
you usually stick up for people so the
word gets back to them that they stuck
up for you and you get brownie points no
no no there was no brownie points here
she stuck up for my mother
because she stuck up for my mug
and that wasn't all then after that
the best was like the next day
when she started throwing people out
that didn't belong there
like she was just going up to people
going you know what mike i was there
that night you were talking [__] about
my sister
get the [__] out of here
people were [__] like leaving and
then she put like a bounty on my
stepfather
she's like when he gets here i'm
throwing him out in 10 [__] minutes
he's not going to last 10 minutes
anybody want to bet me i know exactly
what to say to him
i don't know what she said to him the
first night but he ran the [__] out of
there
and the more and more like the funeral
was like three days awake
but i gotta tell you man the last night
of the week before we buried him i went
to smoke a joint or something i don't
know what i went outside to do
when you're in awake you're gonna get
some air whatever the [__] you do
i went and i
i went outside and when i came back in
zarita was [__] crying on my hands
and knees
by the casket
saying how beautiful you look
you know
i'm gonna miss you i'm gonna miss your
phone calls and [__]
and then i don't know where as a writer
goes and i'm gonna take care of this
[__]
piece of [__] you know i don't know if
she said that she just goes i'm gonna
take care of him make sure he grows up
to be a man
which is what was your dream you know
and right there i was blown the [__]
away guys i started [__] crying
then i saw off of my mother a bump which
was even
the worst thing i've ever seen in my
life
but that's how much she loved her she
was combing her hair in the casket you
know that's as creepy as it gets
but that was the [__] love that they
had for one another and i know my mother
was crazy about it trust me i knew my
mother was great in fact she was the
first person i called after i found him
because i know that's what my mother
would have wanted i called her first
never mind
the sisters in cuba nothing
i called that woman first because i knew
then we buried my mother and let me tell
you something from
november 1979 guys to
you know
july of 84.
she was there for me
and every time i talked to her
she'd cry about my mother even if she
was in a good mood she just go i was
thinking about your mother the other day
this story in cuba we were [__] kids
and i'm like [__]
and you know i was in a bad place for
years
but
her lesson was taught to me at that
[__] week
like as soon as
we buried my mother and i saw her a bit
and then
not only did she she lived in long
island and her drug operation was on 100
and [__] eighth avenue down there i
don't know like third avenue was the
beginning of
spanish harlem and she lived in long
island she she got out of the city at
night and went home she separated her
life and
the apartment i think some puerto rican
ladies stayed in the apartment at night
and watched it
she would drive from [__] long island
to [__] jersey to see me
you know and bring me 200 every week and
bring me
a little weed you know and then i told
her the truth about the coke and i was
buying coke from her which i'm not very
proud of and i don't think she was very
proud of it either
and you know i mean we were tight and
she was very tight to me she loved me
for me
and it just taught me so much about
how much effort you have to put into
your friends
it's
everybody always complains i don't know
friends i'm going to join a [__]
whatever you haven't tried you walk
around relying on your laurels and
that's not gonna work when you're
looking for friends like i've always
said this and this has been my trademark
for years you could take over a country
with three people fidel [__] did it
it's a state of mind you don't need what
happened was in 19 [__] 95 that
stupid show came out and trust me i
watched the show i like i shouldn't say
it's stupid the show friends came on
everybody has this idea
that if you don't have six or seven
[__] friends you ain't [__] everybody
that became like a fantasy to people
you know let's go out and do birthdays
10 of us at a [__] table having get
everybody's giggling till the check
comes
that's
red wine i love it you know all the
[__]
and that gave people like this thing to
listen it's all [__] you're never
going to have six even jesus had a bunch
of friends one turned you follow him
saying to you the
the the smaller the number the the least
that people will [__] turn
and if listen i could put it's like uh
it's like having a family you know if
you got a wife and 20 [__] kids it's
tough to give those kids attention
but you have to figure it out and that's
why you can't give them all attention
because they're 20 [__] kids one of
them is going to come out to be a mass
murderer and the other one's going to
rape a school teacher who the [__] knows
you're not there for them but
if you got three or four kids it's
better the same thing with friends
listen you're gonna have 20
acquaintances you see them every day
what's going on they don't break a
barrier with you and you don't break a
barrier with them and that's okay
you're not going to be best friends with
[__] everybody but you're gonna have
three [__] even me and jersey
since i've gotten back here i thought
that the kids i grew up with were gonna
be my running mates you know what that
was 40 years ago i've accepted their
acceptance we care for each other
we contact each other on a weekly basis
but hey i'm an hour away from them
and they're an hour away from me
so i had to make friends down here and i
got a couple friends on here that i
could tell anything to they know the
[__] i am
one of them is a cop you know i'm dear
friends with bobby you know he lives in
jackson so i talk to him every other
[__] day
and
this is the extent of it for right now
you know i i love joe
ahri's a dear dear
comedy friend
josh wolfe is a dear friend
mike is a dear friend you know
we watch after for everybody mike's
doing a great job with the videos mike
doesn't call me and say i'm a great
friend look at the job i'm doing with
the videos he just doesn't has
understood that [__] i love him to
death you know i watched the latest
you know
uh the album of the week it looked
[__] great you didn't do that you did
that you love me i love you you know and
that's what this is all about you know
so don't worry about having the 19
[__] friends
all you need is three [__]
you could start anything a jiu jitsu
school
i guarantee they took over the [__]
white house on january 6th it started
with three [__] even though i
wouldn't do business with three [__]
people because two of them could turn on
you so what you do is keep it to a low
be the best friend that you can be
check up on
people you know check up on people
people's lives are busy but i gotta tell
you something
you know how many times i've been busy
and somebody has called me
and you're in your busyness
and
you know you're having like a situation
and one of your dear friends calls you
so what's going on how you doing i'm
just checking in with you whatever you
like listen i can't really talk right
now
i'm getting my [__] feet lit on fire
i gotta do [__] i hang up the [__]
phone
and that night when you look through
your phone you're like [__] mike called
me in the middle of the day when i was
going through [__]
he was thinking about me enough to call
and most people do that they'll go this
[__] contacted me when i was
going through a bunch of [__] my
friend's mother died last week
i was supposed to call her before the
wake
and i didn't i i know her i couldn't go
to the weight because i was going to
pennsylvania i wouldn't get back on time
and then this week i'm like i gotta call
her again guess what i didn't call her i
called her boyfriend now and i asked i
said listen
don't say that and i just got caught up
because no it's better you didn't call
her
because she's going through a ton of
[__] right now if you call her this week
she'll be [__] ready for you
and that was [__] tremendous you
always have to check in
always got to check in with your friends
let them know you [__] love them
you know i tell my good friends i love
you not because i [__] hate them
because i love them and i want them to
know when they're out there on the road
and they're out there alone i want them
to think of me you know what i'm saying
that's what i was whenever i get off the
phone with people i always tell them the
same [__] line
don't forget about me it's a line i
stole from john turturro
and to live and die in l.a when he tells
spider-man nemesis not doc [__] but the
other guy i think william defoe
william defoe played the counterfeit on
to live and die in la
a great movie to watch this week after
the super bowl and
when [__] the foe goes to visit him
and john turturro and listen bro i
didn't know who nick was i didn't know
who john was i didn't know nothing i
just loved john in that movie he plays a
[__] uh
a guy that sells counterfeit [__]
money but he goes to she gets arrested
at the airport anyway long story short
he's in the jail in the visitation and
the guy's like listen i have an attorney
call you blah blah blah you'll be out of
here in two hours
and he goes yeah i promise not to come
in your mouth and the check is in the
mail
hey he knocks in the glass he goes don't
forget about me and that's the same
thing i'm telling you [__] on a
beautiful monday morning
valentine's day i hope you have a great
day i hope you enjoyed my little [__]
tata
slash ear beating on a monday morning i
was getting zoomed people but you
[__] people don't want to see the
zoom people to be honest here we've got
so much zoom in our life
that i want to narrow it down in certain
weeks i'll get a zoom for you this week
i finished up the wire [__]
i loved it
i [__] loved it
is it better than the sopranos
is it better than the other show that
you know the one on amc about the
speed dealer i think it's better than
breaking bad
because i like different elements
i like different elements of a tv show
i've already seen all the drugs [__] the
thing that made you love about the
sopranos was
that they incorporated their family life
they incorporated all those little
elements
that you've never seen before on tv and
i think
the why did that
with the lesbian cop
you know mike's was saying he's up to
the episode when
she has the baby and she really doesn't
want to be involved in the baby's life
like the baby was a move that was over
ahead
i got it i've been there i understand
that that's a great dynamic to put in
there they put in so many dynamics in
there the rat the snitch that works for
kemah
that smokes crack and [__] you know he's
all the way in that show to the end
you know
yeah you know they they use so many
elements
to show you a ghetto but they didn't
want to show you a ghetto they wanted to
show you the little beautiful things
about together the little
ins and outs the workings you know
season three
the teacher gets the cop gets fired he
becomes a school teacher
all that [__] or season four i don't
know i don't remember
we'll get dominant in a couple of weeks
to talk about it
and what happened even what happened
with his character it's just i loved
how they put it all together it wasn't a
standalone series it wasn't like
law and order that every week is is a
different episode which i enjoy also i
love all that [__] also i'm not i have
nothing against it but it was a great
show and it's up there with me it's up
there
with the sopranos for me i really
enjoyed it i have not watched sopranos i
know nothing about i won't watch
sopranos now for 10 [__] years i
gotta tell you something
it has grown to me that
the movie i was in the many saints was
an academy award winner i feel really
bad when they announced the award
winners last week
and did they give anything to alessandro
i i don't think that movie won any
[__] oscars
and i thought it was at least get an
oscar for the music you know
and it's really weird what happened with
that movie all across the [__] board
it's
you know when i was doing it and before
i was doing it and during i was doing it
was fun and i really enjoyed myself
but you don't see the other
once you shoot a movie you don't really
see a lot of this [__] to the movie
comes out
it settles i never even watched it on
dvd yet or anything
and i gotta tell you something i was
happy with everything about it i'm sorry
i didn't do better in the box office i'm
sorry it wasn't well received as it
should have been but
the sopranos is a tough fan base to
please i didn't know that until after
the movie
i didn't know that till i went on
youtube one day you know i was looking
at general [__] and i saw
a video is phil leotardo gay
like that was
again a bunch of smart people watching
sopranos
and they took into this that everything
had a sign to it there's a thousand
videos
online that i did not know and they got
hundreds of thousands of hits
and there's people watching these videos
of
you know
they just have so many little was
already buckled this
you know they just throw them out to
confuse you what really happened to the
guy at pines barons you know it was just
a lot of [__] and
if i would have known it was going to be
that tough to please
i would have turned the movie down
listen the whole time i wasn't sure
about this movie i had tom pop on the
podcast and he talked me into it and i
was like okay and then i went in there
like a [__] barracuda and i was all
in and i gave it 100
and i'm very proud of what i do in this
movie i'm not taking nothing away from
that the longest shot i was very proud
of but i got a little [__] up at the
end of that movie and it didn't end well
with the sopranos i was great from a to
z
with taxi i was great for may to z there
were a lot of movies i did that i was
great on there was one movie that was so
bad i had to leave the shooting one
night and they ended up paying me
like i worked till like three and i told
them guys you never told me this was a
night shoot
and i just can't do it no more i'm
falling to sleepy and they're like what
are you talking about you're one of the
leads i go listen
i'll i'll leave my jacket i'll leave my
jacket here
and take the chubby camera guy and put
him on the floor at the end and make
believe it's me dead and they're like
that's a great idea see you later then i
just left
[__] crazy the [__] i did on some
movie sets but we live and we [__]
learn it's monday
valentine's day
thank you very much for listening thank
you for supporting me
i love you [__] with all my
heart i have a little gift for you at
the end of the week to my podcast people
and my patreon people you'll be very
happy but until then tip top mcguck
suckers have a great day and i'll see
you guys wednesday the 16th nice and
[__] early ready to rock and now for
a word for my [__] sponsor jack
all right you savages
thank you very much
for listening to my ear beating it's the
monday here beating with uncle joey and
don't forget the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy listen
it's valentine's day whether you're with
your mate two years
or with them for 20 years relationships
take work
we do a lot for people that we care
about sometimes we treat people better
than what we treat ourselves but i gotta
stop i invest in myself every monday
with the monday morning therapy
i do my goals i do everything i can but
listen i've made great jumps since i
went on with better help online therapy
i take care of my most relationship the
one i have with myself i've been with
dana now for like eight months and it is
tremendous
i talked diary monday morning we get out
of the way
we talk about a snag on the fence
whatever's bothering you and we move
forward and i'm doing great with it
whether it's hitting the gym or making
time for a haircut trying therapy
meditating a little yoga invest time in
yourself
before you do it for other people and
see what the results are but start with
better help it's online therapy that
offers video phone and chat sessions but
if you don't want to be on camera you
don't need to it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy you're not going
to find a therapist today so you might
as well go to better health okay
it's much more affordable and you'll be
matched with a therapist in 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people
have used better health
the joint is sponsored by better help
and listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhealth.com
diaz the joint is also brought to you by
zip recruiter did you know that 90 of
employers plan to make employee
experience a top priority in 2022 listen
you got the world by the balls guys if
you're looking for a job it's a good
time to have a job and if you're an
employer it's a great time to have a job
to offer i know jobs offering flexible
work schedules and working from home are
going to be big in 2022 and if you need
to add more employees to your team their
zip recruiter they're tremendous and
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
joey their matching technology helps you
find the right people for your roles
fast whether you're looking for three
employees or you're looking for 25
employees or your company has
100 employees four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day where
you're gonna get that action at no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the us find the
right employees
for your workplace with zip recruiter
now try it for free at this exclusive
web object ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
on it coming to you too baby boy anna is
one of the best supplement companies out
there i've been working with them for 10
years
i just got a boxing them i just started
my new cycle with black label and i'm
kicking on off selling the jack
that's what honor does for me they got
kettlebells and
club bats i can't help you any of that
stuff for the mace
but the supplements the protein the
mexican chocolate the vanilla
the protein bites which are out of stock
i'm depressed about that but listen just
go to on it and look at the great
selection of supplements that they have
start with alpha brand if you don't like
it they give you a hundred percent money
back guarantee that's what honor is all
about
go to honor press and joey church and
get 10 off your first order i love you
stay black have a great day i'll be back
wednesday
2 16 tip top magoo
[Music]
hmm
so
you